to climb to the world's culinary
pinnacle head for the Swiss Alps in the
village of vowels with a population of
1,000 you might not expect a top-notch
gourmet restaurant but the hotel
restaurant 7132 silver was awarded two
Michelin stars in just two years it's
head chef is Sven väth ma Bosnia
domestic war is mine I can bake it's
always been important to me to go my own
way look at what the others are doing
with this one-of-a-kind nature all
around it's easier for me to create a
one-of-a-kind cuisine a 12-course meal
at the silver costs at least 200 euros
it consists of creations with regional
ingredients like venison with pine
needle tips but also exclusive imports
like scallops is in hunt get half
thousand Northey these are hand
harvested in Norway this is pure quince
juice from my grandma's garden she made
it for me
there are anecdotes behind most of spend
vast Moe's dishes my Muslim [ __ ] that's
all hardened this most anything you have
to have a relationship to the things you
cook I can't cope something that doesn't
mean anything to me for example I used
to eat strawberries from our gardener
and up here in vows we have lots of wild
strawberries clear to me that we have to
tell this story we go into the forest
and gather the wild strawberries then we
mix them with sour cream serve that with
a classic cannon a pastry than time
Troodon claw station Camellia Quebec
Sevilla in the summer and fall VASIMR
and earth team go into the mountains
each week to look for ingredients they
boil them down dry or ferment them for
the winter
Meester sir superfood mummy this is
superfood mountain food that we gather
the food at 2,000 meters where nature is
still intact you can tell the difference
berries take longer to ripen and they're
more robust because they have to
struggle to survive then you taste it in
the product high quality regional
products and multicultural influences
may be why Switzerland is such a
culinary success according to the
current Swiss edition of the restaurant
guidebook Gede mashaallah Switzerland
has the most Michelin stars per capita
in Europe this is natural because many
cultures come together in Switzerland
French culture Italian culture and
German Swiss culture they stimulate each
other then there are other factors
Switzerland has strong purchasing power
a lot of tourism and young cooks from
other parts of Europe like to come here
to Zurich Basel all bound to work and
get ahead of Switzerland's 117 chefs who
earned Michelin stars in 2016
many are only in their 20s and 30s
Andrea's coming odda has sported his 3
stars since 2010 he was 33 at the time
and the youngest chef in Europe with
that many stars
often love the restaurant guides are
more open-minded in awarding stars to
young chefs these days it used to be
unthinkable for a 25 or 30 year old to
receive three stars today it's quite
possible when chef Phan Basma briefs his
staff of 11 unveils stars are the last
thing on his mind it's a burden you're
very proud of yourself and your whole
team but I tried to keep my feet on the
ground get back in the kitchen and make
the patrons happy every day most
important extent that Massimo likes to
surprise his guests with new creations
ideas are what ingredients this Jeff
never ones out of Stella McCartney
presents her first menswear collection
and parts of David Bowie's private art
collection have been auctioned off and
if that weren't enough it's carnival
season in Germany I've got all the
details for you on today's Express